we've been talking about goals about
motivation about memorizing my fifth
question is what would you say the most
important thing to do or to have in
order to be a successful language
learner is it
you know something goals is it hard work
is it innate talent or passion what is
it well first of all I think that if you
consider something pleasant you know a
lot of people use this this word this
expression hard work but I've never seen
it like that I don't believe in I do
believe in hard work but for me it's
always been a passion it's always been a
personal choice is something I've always
chosen to to learn languages so it's
never been hard work for me because they
do things a little bit at a time so I
don't I'm not forced to I don't have to
to go to work in that language right I
have just a couple of months to learn
and or to to say something in that
language so first thing is that if
you're an independent language learning
and you've decided to learn a language
by yourself it should be pleasant so the
first thing that I would say and that
makes you a successful language learning
language learner is to do something do
things that you like doing and that is
that figure out pretty quickly and
that's pretty important what you like
doing they talk about there's a lot of
you know they talk talk they constantly
talk about the best method to learn a
language the best method is the method
you like so there are methods that are
more effective than other speeches they
abide by certain principles they you
know in a the brain friendly way so to
say but basically you have to figure out
what you like so that's that's a very
first thing then you have to put in the
time that means that you have to spend
time with the language what I do is that
even if I spend little time every day
you know people say oh you you don't
learn you don't spend a lot of time in
that language if you consider to hold
the general the the picture I spend a
lot of time for with that language for
example German when I started learning
German I spent 30 minutes a day
as I usually always do with when I start
learning the language but then I when
you get to a certain level you can you
can spend three four hours without even
realizing it for example you go out with
your friends so it's not something which
is just limited to your deliberate
learning on hitting the books but it's
it involves every single aspect of your
life you go out with your friends you
talk you speak German for 3-4 hours and
you haven't realized it but you realize
it Indiana so I spoke four hours in
German you wake up you listen to thirty
minutes to thirty minutes just to German
radio when you don't understand it it
seems like three hours because you get
bored but when you understand at all and
the sense of satisfaction keeps you
going and you spend a lot of time
without even realizing that so spending
the time is very important when you
reach certain levels in the language I'm
talking for example about native
speakers native speakers are always
considered a role model they say how is
possible they speak so well well you
know the reason why they speak so well
is that if you consider the path they
have spent a you know 20 years 24/7 on
that language speaking listening talking
to their friends etc in school etc etc
so if you compare the time that
independent language learners spend 30
minutes it's nothing compared to the
amount of time that native speakers
spend with the language so you have to
spend a lot of time it's a long road but
it gets more and more pleasant as long
as you go you know as long as you move
on so another thing is spending time the
third the third thing is attitude that
means that the psychological factor in
language learning it plays a huge role
in language learning and it's often
underestimated a lot of people in
pedagogy for example they they focus on
the technical aspects of language
learning they're trying to say oh I have
this amazing technique but then they
don't work on the psychological aspect
with all my students the very first
thing that happens is they work with
them on the psychological factor they
don't know it but you have I have
techniques to help the
hope that the attitude has to be what do
you mean by that is you you make them
motivated or psychologically means that
for example I had some students even if
they're they know the language very well
they're a little bit hesitant they don't
want to make mistakes they always try to
say things that they know now the thing
is that in language learning making
mistakes is one of the best ways to
learn a language if you are willing to
accept your mistakes and to correct them
now there are a few ways to do this if
you have a tutor sore a native speaker
can help you the very first thing that I
do is to work on the psychological
factor and say look try to say as many
things that you cannot say like for
example I choose I pick up a topic that
they've never talked about and I say
have you ever talked about this and this
ain't no let's talk let's talk about it
so we start talking about it they try to
save things when they cannot say
something there was something they can
they have never seen an expression I
fill in I say well look you say it this
way when they try to say something they
know about that they for example they
make mistakes I wait for five minutes so
I correct them after a little bit and I
gave them feedback to so called feedback
so working on the psychological factor
means you have to try to venture into
unknown ground all the time you get
feedback from a native speaker a tutor a
friend whatever and then you have to see
you know you can print your mistakes
well I have a lot of different
techniques for that in the sky and they
and then they review their mistakes
so what what do you what I think as a
tutor but as also as a self as a
language learner what you have to do is
constantly venture into an on-ground now
you say this is obvious for some people
but it's not as obvious as it looks
because a lot of people tend to stay
within their comfort zone so they try to
say something they know or they if they
don't know the language very well so
they're intermediate learners they try
to you know always use certain
structures that they know
when they that's the reason why they get
stuck and maybe wonder how can I get to
a c1 I'ma be too you know to use these
intermediate phase how can I make it
further and I say in order to make it
further you have to venture into an old
round if you have a tuna or if you have
a native speaker because I do believe in
the human factor as well you have to use
them that there are resources that are
are as important as books that to start
with I think the human factor is huge
especially when when you speak a
language rather well so making the
anymore is a attitude time and it's your
time and also want to add that it's
extremely important to especially at the
beginning to very work this is like
flexibility is also flexibility means
being flexible towards yourself towards
your mistakes and towards the language
learning techniques it means that
there's if you try to if you're if you
just started learning a language and you
don't like though you know you know like
for example a language series well it's
time to change it if you like the what
you're doing because you find that what
you're doing is a little bit boring try
to vary it a little bit if you think
that you are spending too little not
natl you know too much time to try to
reduce it and see the best if you're
trying to review things try to choose a
time frame that is more suitable to you
so you always have constantly have to
adjust things so that they suit your
needs and your tastes that's what I
believe in it's what I've been doing for
the last 20 years
to explore new
new ideas new ways of learning and being
flexible and and open to making mistakes
flexibility is part of attitude so you
can ascribe it to that yeah okay well
we've already taken a lot of time so
this is going to be my last question
because I don't want to make this too
long although it's interesting but I'm
sure you have your schedule here and
everything there is now my wife
conference but the last question it is
in regard to something that is extremely
controversial in language learning
circles and it is in regards to grammar
you know in your personal studies do you
focus a lot on grammar or do you just
try to inductively kind of absorb the
the grammar you know just through a
translation and reading and listening or
do you actually study you know grammar
rules and so forth okay so let's start
by saying that let's look at kids for
example there's always this deep end I
always say well kid kids learn better
because they do certain things we as
adults we don't do we're adults we don't
do now the thing is that if you look at
kids the reason why they learn it so
well as I said before is that they learn
by listening and by getting exposed to
chunks of the language but most
important of all they learn by from
examples now I I've worked on a certain
field some time ago as an engineer which
is neural networks from the mathematical
point of view what happened is that the
striking thing is that these neural
networks work they try to you know the
people who conceived them try to see how
the example of human of the human brain
human brain like these networks learn
from examples if you give them a certain
amount of examples they start developed
developing automatically developing
patters and that's what kids do and
that's what I'm
adults should do as well if you for
example if you don't understand a
grammar rule you can learn it by using a
scene for example five sentences if you
have five examples four examples of that
enough examples you figure out how that
a grammar rule works inductively as you
said you for how the the the the
language is used to convey a certain
message so what I believe is when a at
the beginning I use these bilingual
texts because I I compare messages by
comparing messages you can infer how
things are said in our transmitted and
conveyed in another language this
doesn't mean that I don't like grammar
when you speak correctly and you speed
your well spoken it means that you've
absorbed the language and you you have
made it yours but this doesn't
necessarily mean that I've used that you
have to use has to make massive use of
grammar books in the case of for example
of languages that are very similar this
is very evident because you compare
Spanish and Italian he well 80% of the
cases you just have to compare words
because the structure is is very very
similar in languages like Japanese or
Korean that's very different because the
structure is completely different but
even then we and that's why I believe
that using a you know a book like a
smell is very useful is that if there's
something you didn't understand you can
always make use of a few grammar notes
that are progressive then explain in a
clear way with examples how you can use
that grammar rule so I wouldn't thought
I don't even like the word grammar I
used like to figure out the fabric the
tissue of a language I I compared
messages and I figure it out then of
course I cannot understand everything by
myself so I you know there's brilliant
people who rolled grammar rules and you
know a grammar rule has to be something
you look you look at after you've seen
some examples because language is
something extra
practical and so basically what I do
normally is that I start by using these
bilingual texts in the beginner phase
and even in the intermediate phase and
then once I've used a lot of you know
using grammar using these grammar
instructions for grammar explanations I
start if I if I want to do it I start I
buy a grammar book and I you know you
know take a look at it on and off but I
don't focus on grammar deliberately I
learn grammar from the language got too
long that said having gone through that
grammar on the text with something you
wouldn't you know learn the grammar
before and after go you know through
basically basically what happens is that
I consider it not for example I'm using
this booklet let me show you I don't
know if you see it this is this is a you
know that the the 112th questions for
Japan and I use like this look these are
bilingual texts and I compare texts to
include the grammar there's a lot of
information here a lot of information
that you can actually get from from from
these things so this is extremely an
interesting book because I'm going to
Japan
so since I'm going to I'm gonna live
there for a little bit I you know I use
these texts to understand a little bit
the the cultural aspects of a very
different culture but it's extremely
interesting so the fact that this book
is so interesting and the fact that it
has bilingual a bilingual version of
that you can infer and you can learn so
much instead of just focusing on grammar
rules because it's in context and
there's always recurring patterns in the
language there are some patterns are
more recurring than others but you end
up figuring out how the language works
by looking at how it works in real life
or in books and interesting always
finding interesting concepts the
concepts so I think that
if you and going back to what I was
saying before if you like doing
you have to like when you're doing so if
you're a grammar fan and you want to
start start by looking at grammar rules
since the very beginning well you know
by all means do so but in channel I
believe that we learn all brain learns
from examples so if you want to make it
enjoyable if you don't like grammar so
much because I you know as a channel why
you haven't met a lot of people who are
huge grammar fans so if you can learn it
in an indirect way as a consequence of
exposure to interesting context well how
much of the batter and he said if you
can go that if you don't go that way you
go because I think it's one of the most
effective ways to absorb the fabric of a
language well should come out in June
2013 I hope that it's gonna come out at
that time probably in time in English
and yeah before before summer before I
moved to Japan also bleh it's not going
to find a lot of time to get to know
more about you thank you thank you Sam
bye